ça peut paraître étonnant mais le métier
le plus meurtrier au Canada c'est celui
de pêcheurs enfin étant plus de 200
pécheurs ont perdu la vie en travaillant
mais pourquoi ce secteur est-il encore
si meurtrier alors que d'autres comme
l'agriculture par exemple voit le nombre
de décès au travail diminué les
chercheurs et des pêcheurs salis pour
tenter d'améliorer la sécurité à bord
[Musique]
un troisième naufrage ce soir en moins
d'une semaine en eau canadienne dans
l'est du pays la nuit dernière environ
25 km laisse des Îles de la Madeleine un
navire de la société madely pêche
assombré par mauvais temps le nazine un
chadutier de 30 mètres qui transportait
10 personnes
déjà six corps ont été retrouvés deux
personnes m'ont toujours à la pelle il y
a deux marins qui ont été secourus et
qui reposent dans un état satisfaisant
c'était il y a 32 ans le Québec vivait
alors la plus grande tragédie de pêche
commerciale de son histoire
quand tu arrives une tragédie mortelle
c'est pas juste la famille immédiate qui
est capable on voit le dommage que ça
peut faire dans toute la communauté
quand tu pratiques le métier de pêcheur
de 14 fois plus de probabilités de
mourir au travail qu'un agent de police
c'est pas normal que nos pêcheurs et un
taux de mortalité plus élevé
cher et le métier le plus mortel au
Canada
à la question connaissez-vous quelqu'un
qui a eu un accident de pêche en région
côtière la réponse est généralement oui
moi personnellement un accident majeur
dans ma carrière j'ai tombé à la route
mon premier bateau de poisson de fond
j'ai frappé dans les roches ici ont été
fatigué puis des nouveaux équipages
avait travaillé dur puis je viens de me
réveiller je retombe endormi pendant pas
eu de blessures heureusement mais le
bateau était perte total
[Musique]
on est à rivière au renard l'un des plus
grands ports de pêche de la Gaspésie
Guillaume sinote pêche la crevette
depuis plus de 25 ans il a commencé très
jeune avec son père aujourd'hui il est
capitaine propriétaire du Manix 5 la
pêche a été bonne pendant le transfert
des crevettes ok l'équipe de Robert
facto installe des caméras sur le bateau
à des endroits stratégiques pour
comprendre les risques d'accident ils
font partie d'un comité dédié à la
sécurité des bateaux de pêche du Québec
moi je travaille auprès des pêcheurs
commerciaux maritime depuis le début des
années 80 et là maintenant la retraite
je peux pas quitter
quitter ce domaine c'est vraiment une
passion pour moi je veux vraiment voir
une amélioration en sécurité des pages
la Flacé représente seulement 4% de la
flotte complète du Québec tout pêche
confondues et subissent 20% des
accidents les plus grands danger à bord
des bateaux de pêche au Québec quand on
fait une analyse
statistique sont des accidents on
constate les accidents mortels
principalement dû aux chutes par dessus
c'est manipuler les chaînes de porte ça
pèse 1000 kg les panneaux les chaînes
c'est lourd c'est des gros équipements
les portes du salut c'est ce qui permet
à ce grand filet de rester ouvert pour
attraper les poissons
une maille une erreur
le bateau puis le la porte une main
c'est c'est ça qui est ta voiture
le comité permanent sur la sécurité des
bateaux de pêche à publier un portrait
inédit des accidents et ainsi d'un pêche
au Québec entre 2005 et 2015 dans le
rapport cap sur la prévention en disant
il en répertorie 748 on a constaté que
les accidents étaient vraiment
diminution et le tendance
se confirme avec les statistiques des
cinq dernières années qu'on commence
analyser présentement par contre une
augmentation un petit peu d'incident
maritimes aujourd'hui les pêcheurs sont
mieux équipés pour anticiper les
intempéries les incidences sont
principalement dus à des brimes
mécaniques les membres du comité se sont
aussi intéressés à la culture de
sécurité des pêcheurs ils ont visité 101
navire et questionner autant de
capitaine en plus des membres d'équipage
ce qui nous désespèrent un peu c'est les
plus petit flottes qui sont pas
inspectés elles sont assujettis aux
mêmes règlements que les autres flottées
mais si on les inspecte pas comment
est-ce qu'on veut faire respecter ça
nos champions toutes catégories c'était
les cadiers de la côte nord
deuxième catégorie et c'est là que ça
nous a surpris un peu c'est les
crevettiers
on se pose la question comment se
fait-il qu'on peut avoir beaucoup
d'accidents malgré une bonne culture de
santé sécurité
au début il faut juste s'assurer que ça
lui accroche pas les gars puissent
sortir ou laisser dérouler
[Musique]
tantôt
il faut des problèmes inutiles
les chercheurs enregistrent aussi
l'exposition au bruit considérable à
bord d'un navire de pêche
l'ergonomie des pêcheurs et les risques
de lésion selon leur posture ou leur
geste
lorsqu'on a vu deux travailleurs
œuvrés pour une même activité de travail
l'activité devant mes yeux était plus
préventive d'un côté à tribord cababbar
on se reportait à penser que les gestes
sont relativement standardisés mais
c'est pas le cas je posais la question
au capitaine il y a il disait
c'est comme ça de père en fils lui a
commencé avec son père son père a
commencé avec le grand-père et ainsi de
suite
[Musique]
comme les crevetiers pêchent 24 heures
sur 24 la fatigue peut aussi jouer un
rôle important dans les accidents
en mer on dort pas tout le temps bien
des fois avec un qui a du poisson en
abondance
parce que on manipule le poisson mais
des fois ça arrive que oui on a pas nos
heures de repos
si mon sommeil si ma santé mentale n'est
pas à point il y a beaucoup plus de
risques de se blesser au dos d'avoir des
entorses lombaires des hernies discales
et je trouve ça intéressant de voir
qu'une autre équipe de recherche de
Terre-Neuve se penche sur l'aspect
sommeil l'aspect vigilance
nous clôtures sont les pratiquement la
seule flottie qui fait une pêche commune
ou turière c'est une période de
plusieurs mois la plupart de nos Flottis
au Québec c'est des pages journalières
côtières très près des côtes
des mesures sont déjà en place pour
prévenir les accidents il existe par
exemple des comités d'ouverture de zone
de pêche qui tiennent compte de la météo
et depuis 2017 Transport Canada exige
que les pêcheurs fassent des exercices
de sécurité testent leurs équipements et
tiennent des registres
sécurité on a des gilets auto gonflables
ou tu le penses
si un bruit d'équipement
on a montré les côtés des bateaux
justement pour livrer des chutes par
dessus bord
on essaie de mettre de l'avant un
équipement avec un casque un système de
communication intégré au casque donc on
va protéger la tête de nos pêcheurs et
en même temps on favoriser la
communication parce qu'à bord d'un
navire de pêche il y a beaucoup de bruit
que ce soit les moteurs d'autres
équipements hydrauliques qui sont
utilisés ou encore le bruit des vagues
le bruit du vent
[Musique]
on a appelé pour de l'aide puis ça
apporte le menu de votre pige le bateau
Toto
majeur
de détresse si vous voulez un homme à la
mer ou un blessé grave là on appelle
pour faire une évacuation médicale
moi en général alentours de 20 minutes
on est pas mal près pour pouvoir partir
du quai là chez les amorces
en tout temps on a un commandant un
mécanicien puis deux matelots
donc en 20 21 sur les 24 appels on a eu
12 qui était par rapport à flotte le
pêche et puis sur ces 12 là il y avait
11 qui étaient débris mécaniques puis un
qui était un comédien les agents de la
gare côtière sont les pompiers de la mer
dans un code d'urgence la loi maritime
c'est que tout Navier qui peut aider
doit aider donc il va avoir un appel
général fait à la radio et tous les
navires qui sont dans cette secteur là
qui peuvent porter de l'assistance sont
en obligation de arrêter ce qu'ils font
puis de poursuivre leur route vers
l'accident pour pouvoir donner de l'aide
pour améliorer la sécurité à bord des
bateaux de pêche continu mais déjà les
auteurs du rapport cap sur la prévention
recommande des activités de
sensibilisation et de formation en santé
sécurité au travail pour les capitaines
et les pêcheurs il suggère aussi à
Transport Canada d'augmenter les
inspections sur les plus petits bateaux
le ministère n'a pas voulu répondre à
nos questions
la flotte des bateaux de pêche du Québec
doit se renouveler dans les prochaines
années le contexte est idéal pour
construire des aménagements plus
sécuritaires les chercheurs collaborent
déjà avec des chantiers navals en
Gaspésie
l'ergonomie de conception est beaucoup
plus rentable que l'ergonomie de
correction c'est des flottes à 80% qui
date des années 80 il y a beaucoup plus
de de matériaux il y a beaucoup plus de
connaissances maintenant qui fait en
sorte que nous pourrions vraiment
diminuer les risques pour les nouveaux
pêcheurs
[Musique]
cette marin pêcheur madelineau et une
biologie périssent dans snaufrage deux
membres d'équipage seulement sont
rescapés le capitaine du Nadine Robert
Poirier et son frère Serge homme de pont
ce capitaine
est arrivé hier
restez
un grand blessé si on veut
malheureusement il va vivre toute sa vie
avec ça c'est triste de voir des choses
comme ça
la tragédie d'une adulte est à mes yeux
vraiment une leçon qu'on devrait
on devrait travailler faut pas oublier
cet accident-là pour la mémoire de ce
genre
les bateaux ont évolué puis la culture
des gars ont évolué aussi les gars sont
plus prudents qu'avant ça on est parti
longtemps puis loin on sait que
l'ambulance est pas proche il faut pas
faire attention pour pas se mettre dans
le pétrin pour rien personne veut faire
sa vie à gagner
[Musique]